hello everyone and sorry about not
making any videos for the past few days
like i i believe two days have uh gone
without me making a video but i have
contracted covid uh and uh well i really
couldn't make any videos the first day i
spent just lying the entire day as i
really couldn't move at all uh and the
the second day was a little bit better
but not all that all that much better
and now the third day i feel mostly fine
you know there's still some general
fatigue going on in the body but i can
use my voice now you know to the full
extent i believe i don't know if i uh
will be able to use it for the entire
video but uh i don't know i feel
confident enough to try showing one game
so we'll see how it goes but yeah if you
guys were wondering where i am i was uh
you know
battling this uh terrible disease
uh so uh this is a game from the final
day of the blitz section of the super
united blitz tournament in croatia
currently uh that was being played in
zagreb uh magnus cross and versus yani
palmish magnus already defeated nepo uh
in the first half of the of the
tournament now uh nepo will have a
chance to bounce back and then we're
going to discuss the standings and what
happened in the tournament in general if
you guys have any of your
favorite games do use hashtag suggestion
and i will go through uh through them
and show them if they are very nice as i
really uh haven't had a chance to go
over them uh so that being said uh let's
uh check it out and also uh if you guys
are interested here is a
a nice photo of the two of them playing
i have uh also prepared that
uh so let me just load it up there you
go uh nicely magnus having the white
pieces uh
what
sorry about that
uh just give me give me a second here
uh there we go
all right
yeah for some reason it didn't show all
right so there we have it there's the
nice photo uh right before the game uh
the handshake taking place uh you can
see that it's a five five minute uh plus
two seconds increment uh magnets with
the white pieces again everything casual
no one has to wear suits no one has to
be you know
uncomfortable as it's really really hot
in croatia uh so you know just a very
nice and uh casual chess by by two of
the strongest players in the world so
let's dive straight into it magnus has
the white pieces and he opens with e4 we
have c5 uh going for the sicilian
defense we have knights to see three
magnets going for the close sicilian and
now d6 we have pawn to d4 captures and
queen captures on d4 knights to c6 and
now uh queen just goes back to d2 you
could also play queen to d3 you could
play queen to e3 magnus goes for the
main line that is queen to d2 and now g6
preparing to fiance to the dark square
bishop uh magnus does the same he plays
b3 he also wants to counter nepo
starscore bishop by fianchetto in his
own bishop
and here usually bishop to g7 will be
played or even bishop to h6 as it's very
annoying for the for the white queen
here but not really we're just going to
play f4 and everything is perfectly fine
however nepo uh
set a very nice surprise for magnus he
plays f5 and it is now already as of
move six that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see how magnus deals
with a c continues developing bishop to
b2 heavy and kettles the bishop bishop
to g7 and now castles queen side we have
queen to a5 now putting pressure on that
a2 pawn also on the knight here uh on c3
and magnus doesn't wanna
wait around he goes for the queen trade
right away knights the d5 offers a queen
trade uh and asks are you maybe
interested in this a2 pawn but you
really don't have
a reason to capture this just uh for
example if queen captures an a2 yes you
are threatening to capture the bishop
but there's also bishop captures here
and then you really have nothing it
would be very silly to do this so
instead after knight d5 nipple trades
queens queen captures on d2 rook
captures and the bishop captures on b2
we have king captures and now king the
f7s magnus is still threatening knight
to c7 check to win the rook here so just
kink to f7 uh we have e captures on f5
uh bishop captures on f5 and now bishop
to c4 threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries knights to e5 now attacking
the bishop and now magnus goes back
bishop to e2 and knight to f6 offering a
trade of knights and magnus traits
knight characters king captures and pawn
to f4 now kicking away nipples knight
from such a beautiful active e5 square
so knight back to d7 and bishop to f3
magnus now claims this diagonal for
himself knight to c5 defending the b7
pawn and also i know what you guys are
wondering here but can't we just play b4
kick away the knight and capture this
pawn because the b4 is always the
winning move
and uh you would be correct like 99
percent of the times but this is one
position where b4 is not winning for
white problem is after b4 there's this
incredibly annoying knight the a for
check and i even though it doesn't look
like much uh for example king a3 you
just play knight b6 and now now you
can't really do all that much because
black is threatening knight c4 check and
this will pick up the rook and it
doesn't help if after knight a for check
you go king here now okay you attack the
knight again knight to b6 and it's still
very very ugly
uh for example if you play bishop
captures on b7 uh now bishop to e6 with
check and now you have a serious
problems there's really no good way to
play this uh king b2 you're going to
play rook 8 rook 8 to b8 now the bishop
has to move uh then
you will have all sorts of problems here
but it's just
you're giving way too much activity to
black
so although it would be fine in most
cases here it just isn't so here knight
to e2 magnus continues development and
now bishop to e4 napo counters carlson's
very strong bishop bishop captures we
have knight captures and now rook to d4
uh we have knight to c5 and now knight
to c3 again uh always keeping an eye on
that the d5 square so king back to f7
nipple doesn't want to be in range of
the
knight to jump
rook to e1 and now rook h the e8 may be
preparing to push
the e pawn uh knights to d5 again going
for that knight to c7 jump and now rook
a to c8
we have c4 by magnus now this pawn is
nicely advanced you don't have to worry
about it being a target on c2 anymore h6
and now rook to e3 the rook is now going
to h3 to try and harass the h pawn uh a6
by nipple and rook to h3 now we have
king to g7 and rook back to e3 putting
pressure on the e7 pawn and nepal goes
back king to f7 uh saying maybe magnus
is interested in a draw by repetition
but magnus says nope uh ponte g4
we have knights to d7 now re-maneuvering
the knight over to f6 again and uh
magnus could try a lot of different
ideas here like pushing the a pawn
pushing the h pawn uh but he goes for
pushing the f pawn it's very very direct
and uh it has a very clear purpose so
here knight the e5 by nipple and now
ponte a4 and here we have g captures on
f5 here with the g5 and nipple could
just close the position and he really uh
wouldn't have all that much to worry
about it would be very very difficult to
make a breakthrough here uh but uh a
nipple very rarely does something like
that we have g captures on f5 g captures
and now rook the g8 he claims the open g
file for himself now he wants to harass
the white king uh this way and he is
also preparing pawn to b5 to bust open
uh the the c file for his own brook and
then he's going to try and uh stir some
trouble here so rook to h4 magnus goes
after the h6 pawn and pawn to b5 nepo
doesn't wait uh he goes for it uh c
captures on b5 a captures and now a
captures on b5 and now uh here is the
moment where uh the position is still
very much playable but you have to play
it uh precisely nipple play the rook the
c5 and this is not the most precise way
to do it and we're going to show why now
with rook to g2 check it is much much
different for example king a3 now you go
after this pawn but via the b file now
you attack the pawn this way and after
let's say knight c3 you defend the pawn
now come to rook to f2 you put pressure
on this pawn and the position is like i
said very much playable however after
this rook the c5 move uh it doesn't
really do all that much you attack the
knight you attack the pawn but magnus
just plays knight to c3 defends the pawn
and now the rook is just being silly
here on c5 so rook g2 check we have king
the a3 and now comes rook back to c8 now
nepo says all right the rook is looking
very silly there i have to
uh defend against the pass b pawn
somehow also i might be able to do some
checks along the a file rook captures on
h6 and now rook to a8 with check we have
knight to the a4
uh the only way to push for a win uh for
magnus and now rook to g4 and now nepo
has some ideas of uh
well putting the uh the the the other
rook also maybe
uh somewhere here and then uh uh
well trying to trying to do some damage
here uh against the pawn or maybe the
pawn advances maybe put the the rook
somehow here uh put pressure on the on
the b3 pawn yeah you know you have the
rooks here so something might come up so
rook to c3 by magnus and now rook to a5
going after the b5 pawn magnus advances
at the b6 now it's nicely protected here
and rook to b5 by nipple and now uh
there is a very very beautiful winning
sequence here for magnus
but it's so beautiful even magnus
himself missed it but you guys are
comfortable in your own homes
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this spectacular winning
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show uh it is rook to
c7 that's the good stuff uh rook the c7
and now after rook g to b4 uh which is
of course uh what nipple wanted to do
now comes the move that magnus missed
magnus played rook to h3 he defended his
b3 pawn
but to actually win this you have to
play f6 brilliant stuff here look at
this position uh going after that e7
pawn and there is no good move uh for
black to defend
you could prolong it a little bit for
example rook captures here king a2 now
this is covered by the knight so you
don't even have that uh and if knight g6
to defend the e7 pawn it doesn't matter
just f captures on e7 and that's it
you're already threatening rook captures
followed by promotion or if knight
captures you can just play rook to h7
check and then of course pick up the
knight with the with either rook it's
completely winning for white
and you don't have to worry about moves
like this to attack the knight because
the knight can never be captured as you
would just capture this rook so
f6 here a much needed move uh without
defending the pawn here but it's a blitz
game that's why i said you guys are
comfortable in your own homes you have
plenty of time uh magnus played rook to
h3 and now nipple has a chance to defend
and he does he plays king to f6
we have rook h to c3 and now rook to h4
going after the uh the pawn here so h3
magnus defends it this way and now rook
to f4
now if the knight
if the knight moves uh you could uh
well do do a lot of
a lot of interesting uh
uh
uh maneuvers here but the real idea
behind uh rook f4 is that you can't
capture the pawn with the king otherwise
your e7 pawn falls so here uh rook
captures on f5 is the idea so here we
have rook to e3 and now we have rook to
f1 and this is a uh well just a terrible
blunder by nippo here again you have to
play king to f7 but just by telling you
that you have to play king to f7 you
will no doubt uh
solve the second puzzle of the of the
video and that is after rook to f1 feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only winning move for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well unstoppable forcing maneuver and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is knight to c3 and now you
realize why king to f7 was necessary
because here
the knight is always eyeing that king on
f6 it seems like it doesn't matter
because the rook covers the d5 square
but what do you do with the rook if you
play something like rook c5 we just play
knight to e for check and we pick up
this rook so obviously that's uh
not happening so rook to a5 check was
played king to b4 and now rook to a6 and
now the d5 square has been vacated for
the white knight magnus delivers this
check king captures on f5 and now just
pawn to b7 and the knight from d5 covers
the b6 square so nipple cannot uh go
after the
uh the pass pawn so here we have rook to
c6 uh but magnus just queens the pawn uh
and that's it he ignores this uh move he
just plays upon the b8 queen and he was
in this position on move 50 that ianni
punished resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here and there
are no tricks there are no no uh
maneuvers you could try so it's just a
dead lost position and of course nipple
resigned here
uh so yeah uh very nicely done by magnus
it's a shame as he was already winning
that he uh missed uh this wonderful idea
of uh after rook the c7 just uh pushing
the f6 pawn uh but like i said i really
hope you guys uh found this one as it's
uh you just have to uh you know ask
yourself okay if we give up the b3 pawn
and then king a2
uh black really really doesn't have a
move here and that's all basically there
is to it uh so yeah that's the game uh
hope you guys enjoyed it uh also uh here
are the standings after the the final
round you can see that magnus carlsen
won the event uh with a half a point uh
lead uh ahead of maksim bashir lagrav
and alireza firuja furuja was in the
lead for the entire tournament during
the rapid and the blitz uh but maxime
i'm pretty sure he won like eight games
in a row and then he just
overtook everyone and he was very very
close to winning uh but yeah the french
duo claims uh second place then we have
janipanishi with 21 points wesley's over
21. jordan fought for us with uh 19 with
15 shakira media linear dominguez uh
wesleyan topalov with 12 and even
shahrich the local hero uh 10 and a half
points uh he had some very good games uh
he defeated magnus uh
in the in the final round i believe yeah
mag also i forgot to mention magnus uh
won the tournament uh two whole rounds
before the end and then he lost the last
two games to alireza and to evan
shahrich but it didn't matter as he
already had plenty of points
uh so yeah that's the game uh i hope you
guys enjoyed it and this very short
coverage uh as like i said i was
i was unable to i presented the games
from the final day to you so if you guys
have any of your favorites uh that you
know where really really good chess was
played uh do feel free to use hashtag
suggestion and i will go over them and
present them most likely tomorrow
uh so yeah once again i really hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
kevin kline ravishing reptiles youtube
omicron uh pikachus scally and ishmael
rivera for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day